I heard that too I love Ed Sheran um I
got to work with him on the voice and
you did a song with him right we did I
did we w we uh I went to I've known Ed
for years and I went to England to write
with him and when I first sat down we
writing a song and he asked me who my
first love was and I said it was my
fifth grade girlfriend Sarah and he
asked me these million questions and
then at the end of the session he's like
hey I got one more song let's write a
song about Sarah and I said you want to
write a song about my fth grade
girlfriend I haven't talked to her in 45
years and you would to talk and we wrote
a song called Sarah about my fifth grade
girlfriend yeah you want to know why I
think that's such a great idea is that
we always I feel like adults always say
like oh they're children what do they
know of Love or what do they know of
this and I'm like I think children
they're not jaded yet exctly you know
what I'm saying I think that kids feel
everything I I never tell my kids when
they come home and they're seven and
nine but they already are like oh I love
him like and I'm like I truly believe
you probably do with your whole heart
like I'm like you know you probably
gonna change your
mind but I just go let you know but like
but yeah I just think it's such a pure
thing and it's there's no other
experience jading that you know agree I
agree I love the song that's such a
great
[Music]
[Applause]
songwriter thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home